Let's see how you did. The x intercept for this equation is 3, 0 and the y
intercept is 0, negative 6. Let's see how we got those answers. Remember when we
are finding an x intercept we set the y value to 0. When we set y equal to 0 in
this equation we get. 2x minus 0 equals 6. Which is the same as 2x equals 6. And
if we divide both sides by 2 we get x equals 3. So the x intercept is going to
be 3 comma zero. To find the y intercept we want to set x equal to 0 in the
equation. When we put x equals 0 in this equation, we get. 2 times 0 minus y
equals 6. 2 times 0 is 0. So we have negative y equals 6. And, we can divide
both sides by negative 1, which gives us y equals negative 6. So, the
y-intercept is 0. -6. If you got the answer right, great work. If you didn't get
it right, don't worry, just go back and look at the video, and try again.